big news for people using or being used
by Twitter the time-sucking tool may be
dumping the like button CEO believes
that since people want more likes on
their comments they might boost the
attention grabbing qualities of their
tweets and that's bad
sounds like ratings but to me that's
like removing seat belts on the
Hindenburg it's not about the
accessories it's about the thing itself
does Twitter have any purpose at all
other than attention seeking no one ever
tweets get out your houses on fire
no Twitter is the world's bathroom wall
allowing the worst part of you to shine
no one is better on Twitter than they
are in real life there are avatars
without souls because without
face-to-face dialogue cues are missed
and cowardice rules is that person being
sarcastic or mean and when reading the
Twitter tweet do you actually care it's
more fun to condemn than comprehend
meanwhile the same biases exist there as
anywhere else the CEO still protects
Farrakhan while banning other noxious
voices and calling it brave because if
you're spineless moral posturing is all
you have left
the first mistake we ever made with
Twitter is thinking that it mattered but
the worst part of it us and our
willingness to be used without content
provided by you or me
the platform wouldn't exist and Jack
Dorsey wouldn't be worth five billion
bucks he's a guy getting rich off dog
fights and we are the mutts I feel like
I'm used every day that I'm on Twitter
Jessie I know when you're having fun on
Twitter it's like eight or nine and you
start getting loose and you start saying
things you shouldn't say that's I like
Craig's Twitter through 8 and 9 and 10
that's the best Craig I don't
participate in Twitter I walk a fine
line as it is yes on television yeah I
think typing things down so it stays in
eternity is too risky for me it is so I
like just as tweet and retweet things I
say on the air and I need the like
button I need to feel like I want to
know what I say and how people are
reacting to it and the more likes I get
the better I feel about myself sure at
least you admit that
to honest wine you don't even you just
stay away from on don't go on as your
friend please don't go
it has commercial value because it can
publicize projects and the parents isn't
alike I don't think it sells anything
like I do you ever no I don't think it
sells books no I think it can alert
people to a segment coming up or
something like that but sales no
problems you know it's a lot of ego
people won't think that you want to hear
what they have to say
yeah but I really agree with what you
said in the monologue because to my mind
there is such a lack of responsibility
on the part of these social media
platforms right and they don't want to
deal with the fact that more than half
of Americans say they've been harassed
in social media demean put down trolled
I can tell your stories and so I I just
think if they were responsible instead
of always saying oh you know we want to
facilitate good conversation but then
they don't protect against people who
are vicious and vile and sorted in terms
of what they say it's damaging to our
country into our society or could you
argue Morgan that it provides a release
so people don't aren't vile on the
street like the trolls end up letting it
out online and therefore it reduces
incidents of violence could that be a
possibility maybe but I actually think
like eight to ten years ago there when
Twitter was younger there was actually
amazing things happening on Twitter
remember in the 2009 Iranian Green
Revolution that almost overthrew that
administration rule that started on
Twitter I was living in the Middle East
in 2011 during the Arab Spring a lot of
that seeing Mubarak and and those
regimes fall the Arab Spring happened
because of Twitter it has devolved since
then but I remember I was at the Middle
East at the beginning of the Obama
administration we were amazed at how
social media was bringing down you know
thirty-year autocrat regimes so perhaps
there's a way to get it back to where
it's taking that as people we don't like
that's a fair point it's an end-around
over tyrants and Trump's indoor-outdoor
the media yes Dana how many Twitter
followers do you have now 2 million a
lot doing a half only a lot it's a lot
and you know what you do it you know how
why you get it because you're exploiting
your dog don't you Jasper has no idea
he's on Twitter
he's definitely not as used as there
should be dog lawyers you're the biggest
problem of Twitter and the like button
when they change it from a star to a
heart yeah just changed everything
because you don't want to love something
you like start it like oh that's good
that's like parting it is gross like
they should have never done that you
don't like you also start things that
you want to remember to go back to you
know true and also have you ever had
complaints from people if you like their
tweet and they'll call
could you please retweet it like have
some guts and retweet it I just I wonder
if all of us should abstain for one week
from Twitter yeah we say that but we
never do I did it when I went to Spain
and it was great way to drop your
vacation oh when I was in Spain yeah
well I was when I was in Milpitas
California